[Applause]  Kylie Jenner really pulled out all the  bus stops to celebrate her BFF stassi's  22nd birthday  yeah Kylie really had a party bus that  says Stas turns 20 to show up to  celebrate and that's just the icing on  the cake  Kylie made it a weekend-long celebration  for Stassi starting with a pool day  Kylie and Stassi you rockin hot pink  bikinis then it was a night out at  Bootsy bellows Kylie also through a  Handmaid's Tale themed bash and the  decor was in same dinner everyone's  names are letters look at my girls Sofia  to me she caught a lot of flack for the  bash though fans tweeting that she  missed the mark turning a show about  women's oppression into a celebratory  theme there was also some sort of brunch  that included Kylie downing a mimosa  there were these giant gold balloons and  finished the epic weekend off a night  and matching PJ's one thing is for sure  Kylie it clearly loved Stassi  [Music]